Speaker 1: I want to start today with an explosive
confrontation that took place during another
one of these Republican Senate hearings.
This particular confrontation involved unhinged
Republican Senator Markwayne Mullin as well,
or with all along side or up against, I guess
you would say, Teamsters President Sean O'Brien.
Teamsters, of course, a union Republicans
tend not to like unions.
Republicans love to frame unions as sort of
like mob entities and the guys or gals who
run unions as mob bosses.
And we've seen that narrative for a while.
The big continuing story since Republicans
have taken over control of the House is the
humiliating face planting and self-destructive
nature of these hearings, the hearings that
Republicans have organized.
And this is happening in the House and the
Senate on big and crossover hearings as well,
on big tech, on weaponization of the justice
system or whatever the case may be.
And even when it is not Republicans who organized
the hearing, they still find new ways to humiliate
themselves.
So let's take a look at this video.
Bernie Sanders was sort of trying to officiate
this thing.
And it is the latest brazen attempt by Republicans
to attack labor, which is what they love to
do.
Speaker 2: You talk about CEOs that are making
all this money.
And what do you make, Mr. O'Brien?
Speaker 3: Well, I'm glad you asked that question.
Speaker 2: I know what you make because in
2019, your salary was, what is this, 193,000?
I'm sure you got some pay raises since then.
Speaker 3: Yeah, well, numbers.
Speaker 2: Are going to average you.
Speaker 1: So basically, like the same salary
as Markwayne Mullin gets as a senator.
That's an interesting thing.
A little higher.
Speaker 2: Yes.
Driver.
The feeder driver makes 35,000 a year.
That's what you bring.
Speaker 3: That's inaccurate.
That's an inaccurate state.
Facts right here.
State facts.
Speaker 2: That's an average U.P.S.
feeder driver makes 35,000.
If you don't know your facts.
And maybe you.
Speaker 3: Should.
I know because I negotiate the car.
Speaker 2: So I say one thing to you.
What do you bring for that salary?
What do I bring?
What do you what job have you committed or
have you have you started?
What job have you created?
One job other than sucking a paycheck out
of some other by somebody else that you want
to say that you're trying to provide Because
you're so.
Speaker 1: Remember, the narrative here is
unions are oppressive.
The people who run them take money in exchange
for nothing other than forcing the workers
to pay union dues.
And we would all be better off if there were
no unions and the workers had a direct relationship
with the companies.
Now, of course, we know that that's not the
case, and we know that as a result of the
unions and being able to collectively bargain
in this way, the workers actually end up earning
more on average, all else being equal.
But that's not the story that Republicans
like to tell about unions.
Speaker 2: You're going to pay dues.
Speaker 3: You know, we don't force you.
You're out of line.
Speaker 2: No, don't tell me I'm on of line.
Don't tell me I'm out of line.
You can tell me.
Speaker 3: I'm trying to frame you very misstating
your mouth.
Yeah, because you don't.
You're going to come out.
Shut my mouth.
Yes, I do it all day, tough guy.
I'm not a physical holder.
Speaker 2: But don't sit there and tell me
I'm out of line.
Speaker 3: Senator, you made a statement.
You asked the question.
I didn't ask your question.
You did it by the question.
You asked the question about, Well, what do
you mean let him?
And his.
Speaker 2: Retort is.
Speaker 3: Well, you may think it's rhetorical
to me like a question.
Let him answer the question.
Speaker 2: I'm not yield my time to him.
So if you're going to let me keep my time,
that's fine.
Speaker 3: You'll have your time.
Let him you ask a question.
He has a right to answer that as far as my
salary goes.
My salary?
If you follow me around, I walk.
I actually look at this building.
I bet you I work more hours than you do twice.
But it is impossible.
But that is.
Speaker 2: That's true.
So you know what?
Hard work.
Speaker 3: Second, when a public judge will
be doing it, we hold greedy CEOs like yourself
accountable.
Speaker 2: You call me a greedy C.
Speaker 3: Oh, yeah.
You guys, you want to talk my salary?
I'll tell you what do I make?
What did you make when you were in your company?
Speaker 2: I made my company.
I kept my salary down to about 50,000 a year
because I'm now this.
Speaker 1: We all know this game.
This is so just.
I kept my salary down.
And of course, as CEO, Markwayne Mullin made
tens of millions of dollars towards his net
worth from Non-salary compensation.
Typical move.
Maybe he thinks nobody else knows that.
But we know that game.
Speaker 2: Every penny into.
Speaker 3: It.
Okay.
All right.
You mean you hid money?
Speaker 2: Oh.
Speaker 3: Oh, oh.
Hold on a second.
Speaker 1: Okay, so there's a couple of different
things here that I think are important to
mention.
One of those things is the general idea that
Republicans want to put out there.
And I don't even want to say that Republicans
believe they may not believe it.
As we know, a lot of this stuff is just performance.
The idea that they put out there is that rather
than a tool or an infrastructure that allows
workers to organize and to pool their negotiating
strength in order to obtain better salary
and benefits from a situation in which an
individual worker has disproportionately little
power.
Right.
That's essentially what the union allows a
workers to do in order to get higher salary
and better benefits.
The union they frame as almost like a leech
that just collects dues forcibly, which, by
the way, often is not the case that you're
forced into the union and to pay dues.
In fact, sometimes it's the opposite, where
even if you refuse to pay the dues, the union
still represents you.
But that's a detail that depends on the union
and it takes away value.
The idea is, Oh, the workers come out with
less because not only do they end up having
to pay the dues, they don't even get a higher
salary or better benefits.
We know that that's not the case.
I mean, it's been studied endlessly and we
know that's not the case.
So that's number one.
And the number two, with all of these Republicans,
some personal hypocrisy is not far behind
and it is not lost on me.
And I hope it's not lost on you.
The irony or the absurdity of Markwayne Mullin
calling the Teamsters president with a low
six figure salary, the greedy CEO, when the
entire point of the Teamsters is to negotiate
better pay and benefits for for tons of different
workers.
When Markwayne Mullin's net worth and his
assets exploded by tens of millions of dollars,
tens of millions of dollars over the last
few years.
So they are pathetic.
Yes, they are hypocrites, yes.
But they also have to lie about unions.
Now, I am not an unreasonable person when
it comes to unions.
I recognize that there are lots of small businesses
where a union doesn't really make sense.
And I am not someone who goes around as this.
Every business should be unionized.
That's just not my view.
I've not come to believe that that's the best
thing.
But when you're talking about these organizations
with tons of workers, electricians, electricians,
union trade unions for particular companies,
UPS, etc..
The dynamics of those companies and the sheer
scale of those companies are such that there
has to be some mechanism for all of these
employees who have shared interests to be
able to pool their power.
Because remember, when there are 30,000, 60,000
employees or whatever the case may be, one
person, if forced to negotiate individually,
has relatively little power because they can
just be excluded or pushed to the side or
their influence minimized when the negotiation
is happening.
Collectively, that is a very different situation
and it puts large companies in the position
of having to really come to the table, not
necessarily in good faith, but at least willing
to negotiate in a real way.
So very interesting exchange and shows the
continued hostility towards labor from the
modern Republican Party.